The answer as to which way you should work
it is, well it all depends, that there is
no real correct answer. because it's possible for your
home to work with either model. If the thermostat determines
how hot the heater is, then the first answer
is correct. you know, set it high first. That'll
get you to the correct temperature as quickly as
possible. But, you know, that's not how most homes work.
In most homes, the second answer is correct, because
the home heater either turns all the way on, or
all the way off. We call that bang, bang
control, all the way one way or all the way
the other. The thermostat turns the heat on full
until it reaches the set point, at which point it
turns it off. So, setting the temperature too high doesn't
do any good. It doesn't speed things up and worse,
if you forget to turn it back, well the house keeps getting hotter and
hotter and hotter. Wasting energy and maybe
making you uncomfortable by now being too hot.